so he began in Russia where its defense
Ministry says 63 of its servicemen have
been released by Ukraine Kiev says 116
ukrainians have also been allowed to
return home now according to Moscow
amongst the Russians freed are those who
work in a sensitive category United Arab
Emirates was involved in the
negotiations now we have correspondence
in Moscow and Kiev let's start with
Osama bin Javed there in Moscow tell us
a little bit more about what we know of
these Russian prisons who've been
released
we're never interested
but the Russian Ministry of Defense says
that these people are now being treated
for psychological and medical help
they're able to contact their relatives
and it was made possible to get them
released so you have to remember that
they don't use the word swap with the
help of mediation from the United Arab
Emirates we've seen in the last few
months that these releases have become
routine where Moscow and Ukraine
exchange prisoners obviously we've heard
from cave that they have been receiving
more prisoners than Moscow but this has
been a case that we've seen a number of
times in January there was a release in
December there were a couple of releases
and then going back to September where
the releases were facilitated but
facilitated by turkey and Saudi Arabia
this time around it's been facilitated
by the United Arab Emirates the ministry
of Defense specifically thanks them and
you have to remember that this is a
country which has so far not given into
any of the sanctions that the West ones
imposed on Moscow we know that the chief
Mohammed bin Zaid visited
Vladimir Putin and also discussed the
issue of Ukraine so it is a part of the
exchanges that we've seen happening in
in routine but in the last few minutes
we've heard from the Russian foreign
Ministry the spokeswoman from the
Russian foreign Ministry talking about
the EU Summit which took place just
about 24 hours ago a significant event
which happened in Kiev saying that the
EU Ukraine Summit confirmed that for the
sake of weakening the Russian Federation
and U.S interests Brussels continues to
recklessly support quote neo-nazis in
cave and the EU calls for peace
according to the Russian foreign
Ministry are hypocritical when they're
ready to invest in the continuation of
hostilities for as long as it takes so
ratcheting up of the rhetoric that we've
seen from both sides in the last 24
hours but it does seem that there is
some diplomacy which is taking place
through which they're at least able to
exchange prisoners of War indeed Osama
thanks very much for joining us there
from Moscow let's go over now to Keith
where we can speak to our correspondent
Zane basavi Zayn what are you hearing
about this in Ukraine
well the Ukrainian president's office
announced this as a cause for
celebration 116 prisoners of War being
released uh the intelligence confirms to
us that including today this is the 37th
prisoner swap that has taken place since
the War Began since the initial Invasion
last year and in that time prisoners
have been swapped in the hundreds at
least
1646 Ukrainian prisoners have been
released according to officials in Kiev
but those that are coordinating these
swaps these efforts say that there are
thousands more that remain in Russian
hands soldiers as well as hundreds of
civilians forcibly removed into
Ukrainian territory throughout the
course of this conflict and those are
just the best estimates that they have
in terms of who Russia has taken and how
many Ukraine unions they're currently
holding and of the civilian numbers only
about a hundred or so have been returned
so even though this is a cause for
celebration in the capital today those
that are coordinating these efforts say
there is still a long way to go to get
everybody home indeed and meantime Zayn
events on the ground we're hearing of
more power outages in Ukraine can you
tell us more about that
that's exactly right we've just heard
from the government that a an accident
of a significant scale according uh to
the press release is an accident at a
high voltage substation in the Odessa
region has caused power outages
throughout the region the scale is
significant and we are hearing that
restoring power to that area will take a
very long time and we're still not sure
exactly how wide the impact of that is
in the Odessa region this of course has
been going on for some time Ukraine has
been struggling since September of last
year to keep its critical infrastructure
to keep its electricity grid alive in
the midst of constant Russian
bombardment of these civilian assets
this electricity grid that Russia has
been very effectively to a very high
effect been hitting since September of
last year and this latest setback comes
just the day after an EU delegation
promised low consumption light bulbs
generators and solar panels to deal with
what was already a very very seemingly
insurmountable problem in terms of
keeping this electricity grid alive so
this only adds to what was already a
very critical situation for the national
power grid okay Zane many thanks for
that update there from Keith